on midnight sky which i recommend
everyone watch it's
so much fun and it's right there on
netflix but um you go to iceland and
shoot this thing
and uh those scenes where you're
outdoors is it true your eyelids froze
shut
is that true what do you mean your
eyelids and and then
your eyelashes freeze shut and you can't
literally
someone would have to hold me i'd have
to hold their hand and they walked me to
a van
and i'd take a blow dryer and it would
happen in
60 seconds and literally it was like you
after that and so every take you'd be in
there like and then you'd run back out
and
you know shoot is that still fun like i
would think at this point in your life
you got all the money you need and
everything you ever you ever say to
yourself when your eyelids are frozen
shut and someone's blow drying your
eyelids do you ever say you know what
the [ __ ] am i really doing i got kids
now
i got this great wife i got the place oh
that's hormone i got kids now that's why
i go away to iceland you know
is it hard for you though with the you
know lockdown i mean you can't have the
500 nannies you know you know
you're a guy who's always been used to
his own time you know what i mean
it's difficult right i mean it's it's
got to be challenging
well look i mean first of all we only
have
had one nanny and uh and i will say that
it's you know for again this kind of
goes back to lifestyles of the rich and
famous nobody wants to hear
anybody who has a house and has space
and air and a
and a job and doesn't have to worry
about food or here
you complain so right i'm not going to
complain about anything
but but it's it is unusual it's funny
because i started
in in some ways you know the lockdown
has been
funny because i've been back doing the
things i used to do
a long time ago which is you know i do
seven loads of wash in the you know the
day and i'm
mopping the floor and i'm i'm the chef
at the house and
there's a movie i'd like to see you
doing all that stuff yeah mr mom i mean
literally i honestly it's literally like
my mother in 1964.
anything you want to say to america
there must be a message of hope
a bit of wisdom we should all remember
we're gonna get
through this it's been a [ __ ] year and
uh and and we're gonna get through it
and we're gonna have
um these vaccines are gonna be they're
gonna take hold and we're all gonna get
through it and to
hang in there we got a couple more
months a few more months to get
through it don't don't bail on it now
we're gonna all get through this thing
together and
you know put on a [ __ ] mask i love it
leave it at that
you